in the end it was the fans in the red of
denmark and not of wales who were
celebrating
the supporters of the losing side
leaving the stadium crushed
some close to tears others unwilling or
unable to talk
about what had happened in the previous
90 minutes
wales had started positively with
captain gareth bale shooting just wide
after nine minutes
but denmark were aggressive and wasted
no time with casper dolberg scoring a
goal
26 minutes in and it was dahlberg who
hurt wales for a second time
taking denmark to two-nil at 47 minutes
wales tried to fight back but saw missed
opportunities for its captain
and midfielder joe allen the pain for
wales would last until the very end of
the match
with three minutes left denmark's
joachim mayler found
himself with huge amounts of space and
netted a third goal and a fourth was to
follow
in the final moments i don't know what
can i say
what can i say um i
i don't have words
it's all it's all come to an end you
know what i mean it's just sad
it's just sad yeah yeah so they were
painful images for the few hundred
whales fans
who'd made it to amsterdam starting the
day
in buoyant mood covert restrictions had
prevented supporters traveling directly
from the uk
and many who were here had spent a lot
of time and money
getting to the match i've traveled from
the uk basically from heathrow via kiev
tobacco
either from baku to rome
with them travelled from rome by a car
by
a pisa by the italian riviera to milan
uh we took a train from milan to to
amsterdam via frankfurt basically yeah
a committed fan absolutely yeah a win
cherished by fans of a team who lost
arguably their best player at the start
of the tournament
when christian erickson suffered a
cardiac arrest
after what happens with erection we have
all been sitting
at home on our couches and cried and
that's why there's ten thousand danes
in amsterdam even though there's corona
welsh hopes of emulating or even
exceeding their 2016 success
when they reach the semi-finals have now
been thwarted
uk ambitions now rest with england
and perhaps the only consolation for the
many thousands of welsh fans who didn't
get to the match
is they didn't have to watch the defeat
in person
michelle clifford sky news amsterdam